c'est maintenant le moment de l'invité
de la semaine elle est née à la
télévision on l'a connu on a tous connu
d'elle ses frasques ses prises de poids
ces pertes de poids cccc problème c'est
téléralité son argent sa vie ses amours
c'est pour ça qu'on aime tant vous
l'adorez le fait très peu de télévision
elle a accepté celle là vraiment pour
nous parce que nous fait confiance elle
va répondre aux questions des
chroniqueurs à vos questions avec le
hashtag tpm people c'est l'invité de la
semaine celle ouanna
[Applaudissements]
merci à mon avis merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté vraiment merci beaucoup à cet
anneau nar on va parler de tout je pense
que t'as jamais été autant en forme
c'est non mais en forme en nombre et
noir en forme
heureusement ouais voilà tout dans la
tête tout retour le physique trop bref
reflète juste le mental on a bien
compris on va te poser toutes les
questions qui m'a dit au téléphone qu'on
pouvait poser toutes les questions tu
pouvais répondre ya plus le filtre est
aujourd'hui oui mais d'abord pour ceux
qui n'auraient pas vécu en france ces 20
dernières années
retour sur la carrière sur la vie de loi
nre magnéto et ensuite on en parle à
lens
des lignes qui s'y tient revoilà le
wanna même derrière une mosaïque qui ne
la reconnaîtrait pas il y à tout juste
17 ans elle débarquait telle une
apparition à loana et encore je vois le
wanna gagnante du premier loft story la
jeune fille alors totalement anonyme
devient immédiatement star de
téléréalité à la sortie on aurait
peut-être pu vous préparez un petit peu
davantage à la maison d'arrêt de laon se
démarquer complètement ouais on nous
avait vraiment rien dit et on pensait
même nous vers la fin de du loft
on pensait que l'émission ne marchait
plus donc on s'est dit il faut qu'on
pourra sortir heures à personne
bien au contraire avec le succès
historique de l'émission loana va
pouvoir tout essayé mannequin pour jean
paul gaultier
elle écrira même ses mémoires et
poussera la chansonnette
aïeux mais bon tout ça ton toujours un
peu à plat heureusement loana sait
parfaitement jouer avec les médias et
peut refaire parler d'elle en 15
secondes
preuve à l'appui elle est à la radio ses
dires de l'atonie des qu'elle comprend
qu'elle est filmée un ac en ligue 1 oui
c'est ça le visage et le buste
elle comprend vite et improvise votre
invité ce matin et loana oui c'est l'un
des visages les plus scrutés de la
décennie c'est pas le visage à mon avis
attention ces boulots à nassau ajouté
buzz assuré
mais les buzz ne font pas une carrière
loana tourne en rond loana s'enfonce le
conte de fées des débuts vire au
cauchemar
je me suis un peu perdu choquera comment
ça j'ai quelques déboires pour
médicaments d'alcool tout ça c'est un
peu une période noire est un mal an je
me reprends 2018
loana sort un second livre et nous
revient métamorphosée en couverture de
magazine classe est rayonnante
mais loana reste loana et sitôt la nuit
tombée c'est bost se font plus osées
[Applaudissements]
on a lancé notamment dans les boîtes de
personnes sensibles et blanc avec une
petite tenue c'est quoi c'est du cuir
c'est du latex a piqué sa daniel moreau
dans le film one aujourd'hui de quoi
vite elle est ce qu'elle a des amours
quels sont ses projets ses rapports avec
sa fille tout le mal qu'on peut lui
poser toutes ces questions parce qu'elle
sait qu'ici ce sera avec fait avec
bienveillance sans aucun jugement
donc voilà on va commencer le tour de
table des chroniqueurs va démarrer que
sébastien va lier la paparazzi quelle
est ta question pour l'eau n'a alors
loana jennifer a dit qu'elle a fait une
dépression parce qu'elle sentait un peu
trop traquée par les paparazzi et est ce
que les paparazzi et la presse people
ont joué un rôle dans votre descente aux
enfers pas du tout justement à la
renverse
ils ont montré le meilleur du pire pour
moi c'est pas du tout ça les préparatifs
ont souvent accompagné montré des jolis
moments et canton j'étais à mal a paru
dans les journaux tout simplement c'est
parce que j'étais mal à ce moment là
mais il aurait pu montrer beaucoup plus
pire et je les remercie donc aucun
moment où il ya eu tes sales moments
mais on en parle on se dit tous les
tentatives de suicide tout ça et tout
c'est pas du tout parce que d'une sorte
de traque et n avaient rien à voir non
c'est ont plutôt soutenu les sexes est
plus soutenu puisqu'en fait il fallait
bien qu'il vente ou quelques photos mais
on sait ce que dit il ont montré le
meilleur du pire veut dire les photos de
mode babel qui était ouais c'était pire
que d'en bas que chez toi et tu sortais
pas croyez-moi ça jamais été en bas de
chez moi j'anticipe a jamais senti
traqué parce que quand je veux quand je
voyais s'ils voulaient faire une photo
pas temps en temps j'allais fait vous la
fête comme ça la photo comme
s'appréhender tranquille d'accord c'est
le secret et même quand je pose mais
quand on prend en photo dans des moments
qui était plus compliqué dans ta vie tu
avais plus de poids te sentais pas bien
qu'on ne prend en photo ce reflet
l'acquis qui n'allait magazine bien sûr
mais c'est ce qu'on lui donc quand ils
n'inventent pas il nous montre s'était
pas non plus c'était ma vie donc c'est
bien ma vie aux autres people qui se
plaignent des paparazzi
tu t'en sors bravo daniel moreau mais
question ça envoie n'existerait pas
mallié dont robert que jennifer regarde
pas la télévision
très bien née sophie marceau qui s'en
étaient pris à des paparazzi daniel
votre question alors loana est ce que
vous avez été choisi pour faire le loft
le loft parce que vous étiez il avait
senti vous étiez fragiles ou est-ce que
vous êtes devenu fragile à cause du loft
et de cette expérience assez bonne
question c'est l'état qui t'a rendu
fragile
j'étais déjà fragile avant j'ai pas été
prise pour ma fragilité
j'ai été prise pour les 2 loana qui
était très sensible d'un côté et l'autre
côté très exubérant ces deux ces deux
facettes mais en fait c'était dur je les
avais plus longtemps je vois là j'avais
des blessures anciennes
en fait au fur et à mesure du temps
elles sont sortis mais c'est la boue pas
sa mort arriver c'est pas du tout la
célébrité qui donc ceux qui disent que
c'est à nous de la télé réalité que
derrière lui tous tes soucis la descente
aux enfers les tenté de suicider tout ça
toi tu dis que ça n'a rien à voir
elle se rencontre on les fait partout
ouais il ya beaucoup de gens qui
rentrent sont nouvelles rencontres on a
mangé rencontre mais c'est pas la télé
qui fait pas la télé non ben c'est pas
changer ma jr c'est bien j'ai envie
c'est une question qui dérange parce que
le but vraiment ici il n'ya pas de
jugement et tout c'est aussi des
journées toujours la stricte marche face
à ben ouais ça aussi c'est bien le dire
parce que franchement dieu sait si on a
tapé dessus
guillaume je sais que dire manqué de
vous connaissez vous avez produit
l'émission ensemble votre question à
wana on se connaît depuis depuis très
très longtemps un clown alors là on a
justement parce que j'étais pas content
quand elle l'a fait apte à tarbes c'est
pas ça mais tu as tu as les crimes y est
tu as gagné de l'argent qu'à lancer des
marques de vêtements tu avais acheté un
appartement grâce au lavandou et du coup
aujourd'hui quelle est ta source de
revenue aujourd'hui puisque c'est mon
inquiétude c'est qu'un jour tu n'es plus
de toi tu sais on en parlait beaucoup de
quoi de quoi vivez-vous aujourd'hui loi
de pie x tu vivras je vis en fait toutes
les années où je travaille en tant que
soliste et j'ai vendu mon appartement
ouais voir une cagnotte et et changer
d'endroit je l'adorais mon appartement
il s'est passé trop de mauvaises choses
dedans et donc j'avais envie de le
vendre pour commencer une nouvelle vie
je m'éloigne c'est à dire que pour
l'instant vous on va vous vous taper
dans la caisse commune
j'ai mis de côté tous temps en tous sens
je suis quand même pas mal de choses et
puis c'est les pourcentages je me fais
un salaire tous les
vous avez beaucoup d'argent de côté
douane on peut dire un peu de chose ou
pas c'est quoi beaucoup d'enfants et
bien je vit confortablement avec ma
maman achète un appartement pour plus
tard c'est toi je suis inquiet pour elle
achète un toit pour plus tard même une
petite maison louis hage savent quelque
chose
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui vous
touchez encore des à olonne appartement
vous qu'il y ait encore de l'argent demi
tandis que j'ai donc de côté et penser
un placement est alors non je touche
plus rien de tout ce que j'ai fait
l'argent a été ça peut vous permettre de
vous confortablement pendant encore des
années
pas mal d'années ouais après à lui après
si c'est pendant des années je sais pas
elle garde son capital à la belle a bien
fait il dividende
myriam est myriam palombes à question
oui bonjour loana alors vous avez fait
énormément de conférence de presse
[Applaudissements]
on vient vous avez beaucoup de
couvertures de magazines voilà depuis
que vous êtes est sorti du lot
est ce qu'il ya des choses qui ont été
publiés coup était fausse et qui vous
ont fait beaucoup de mal
une de public de closer de diana mais
peu importe puisque le nom annonce a
aucune couverture mais rien ne m'est
rien n'a été forés avec un truc qui a
été dit qu'elle était faux dans ta
blessés rien n'a été faut tout était
vrai mais c'est l'invité idéal paradis
après stupples eu des bonnes choses mais
c'est incroyable pour elle la nature à
copenhague en m'éloignant bateau est sur
un truc quelques années encore on
pouvait pas du tout parlé de votre fille
c'était très compliqué on connaît ou
pour les gens qui ne connaissent pas
l'histoire avec votre fille qui a été
agent track et ça continue sur ce sujet
alors à l'entretien parle pas d'autre
film jusqu'à question était très bien
vous ciblez vous faites bien de le dire
on n'en parle pas mais la question était
côtier idée une où justement il en parle
ça m'aidait pas que ça vous fait plaisir
quand même nom ils l'écrivent m'afficher
partie de ma vie mais c'est pas un sujet
sur lequel j'ai envie de parler d'accord
n'y avait pas des choses fausses qui
étaient écrites tout ça n'a rien et
nonda ils l'ont dit et j'ai cassé ma
fille à l'orée des journalistes at il
dit
mais j'ai pas envie d'en parler voilà je
préfère et bien c'est pour ça qu'on ne
parlera pas loin de moi j'ai la patience
et si on se dit tous mais comme qu'on
n'avait pas préparé l'émission puisque
mais pas dit avant on avait des
questions dessus on les enlève
j'ai pas qu'ils nous posent des
questions sur sur votre fille comme ça
au passé à autre chose montrez nous
c'est un grand journaliste inventé un
truc voulez mon oreillette
madame autres il ya des rumeurs qui
courent il ya des bruits qui disent que
vous risquez partir à l'étranger vous
avez envie peut-être de quitter la
france est ce que c'est vrai et si oui
pourquoi et avec qui je sais c'est un
petit projet un petit projet que j'ai
fait avec ma maman
on aimerait voilà dans le futur ouvrir
une maison d'autres en algues havre
boussens on est à gâvres dans le sud du
portugal
ah bon nous avons une maison d'autres là
bas je ne sais pas pourquoi je mettrai
la main baba la maman là bas elle sera
lié l'abri du besoin qu'on sait qu'en
france avec la retraite et tout ça et
comme on dit à l'air l'argent n'est pas
éternel vous pourriez investir l'argent
qui vous reste pour acheter quelque
chose au portugal en date fois qu'on a
le temps de venir des gens magnifiques
lots ça va être est ce que le portugal
un choix que de hisser leur look
puisqu'il rejoint ma mère qui m'a dit ça
je fais une piscine rose quand vous
dites qu'une c'est un projet ça veut
dire on en parle comme ça tu entends dit
non où vous regardez le projet est
avancé ça on a décidé ça parce qu'on est
tombée amoureuse de cette région quand
on n'y a été est et on s'est dit
pourquoi pas alors j'ai géré ses potes
marquer quelque part loin n'a pas quitté
la france ça c'est vrai ça va pas être
tout de suite ce qu'on veut vraiment
quand même du temps et puis voir si on
peut le faire mais j'aimerais bien me
lancer dans cette aventure pour de bon
l'udc
du coup vu les restes ya une question
aux modèles canon allait si bien que
donc du coup je change ma question je
vais vous parler 2010 mais du coup je
vais changer le passé pour un coup j'ai
un petit peu mais vous avez parlé de
votre poids beaucoup vous avez fait
jusqu'à 112 kg 115 kg 1 vous êtes passé
à 86 kg alors des faits un résultat nous
a fait une sleeve et vous l'avez
beaucoup raconté vous êtes très
transparente sur ça alors est ce que le
but justement c'est de redevenir la
loana qu'on a vu dans le sujet qui était
justement si le fil etc
vous voulez aller jusqu'à où justement
dans votre transformation est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes au top
alors en fait qui le marque quand j'ai
fait cette opération j'étais en obésité
morbide je faisais plus de 120 kg donc
ce n'est pas un caprice de je veux
perdre 10 kilos 5 kg ça c'est pas vrai
il y avait une vraie mesure d'urgence
car je les fais et puis j'ai pas de j'ai
pas envie de redevenir celle que j'étais
j'ai envie de me plaire mois devant la
classe et me dire voilà je me retrouvais
mon image qui me plaît après je pourrai
jamais
je suis le tien apprennent ce livre
alors c'est comment parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de stars ont
fait ça vous êtes intéressé non non mais
je sais qu'elle bride jeunes femmes qui
sont intéressés qui disent que c'est le
remède miracle pour maigrir c'est un peu
quand même quelque chose de très
médicale à prendre à la légère
il ya des compléments alimentaires à
prendre tout le temps et un régime
alimentaire à suivre donc on comprenne
bien après les gens qui ne connaissent
pas l'opération s'est on enlève une
partie de l'estomac des trois-quarts de
l'estomac her2 comme à l'aller voilà ce
qu'a fait mariah carey vient c'est ce
que vient de faire mariah carey
bassamois bientôt mais je veux bien car
elles connaissent pourtant droite oui ça
fait partie des dérives parce que je
suis le mois mariah carey n'est pas en
obésité morbide a été vraiment dire aux
jeunes voilà évidemment et j'ai une
question dans la question trop bas il
vous est sorti un livre à peu près un an
donnez-nous parier tous de votre poids
de drogue là ce livre il ay là il a bien
marché c'est libre là bas et bien marché
ouais bien sûr en tête des ventes le
livre que de l'année dernière il était
en tête des ventes on avait fait un
sujet avec lui avec lui avec m je ne
savais pas seulement catherine moi
j'aimerais vous parler un peu de votre
vie privée parce que depuis 17 ans que
l'offre ait lieu il ya vous avez des
idées des hauts et des bas terrible
c'est extrêmement violent pour vous où
en êtes-vous des privés ce que vous
arrivez à construire une vie personnelle
il veut savoir si la nuit non mais
revenons à la vie privée ça peut être
plein de choses parce que vous avez un
petit copain aussi oui ma façon pas
virer tout est ce que tu as un mec non
pour savoir d'un côté et ma vie
professionnelle j'arrive à différencier
les deux camps jeudi privée cindy
sentimentale ils ont raison c'est ce
qu'on peut construire quelque chose de
sadaka ce monde un peu violent dans
lequel vous êtes
il faut qu'il soit préparé le monsieur
est non mais c'est pour ça qu'ils
restent pas moins des chats pression ça
c'est vrai oui mais non ça vous empêche
d'avoir une vie sentimentale équilibré
oui bah bah ma notoriété pas de moi ça
c'est sûr donc voilà je cherche un
garçon corrobore on peut dire une petite
petite quarantaine bien dans sa vie tu
30 km/h au houga
[Applaudissements]
et c'est par hasard c'est monsieur qui
est devant son écran et de l'autre côté
je cherche la même chose
voilà ah ben voilà enfin casting on se
partagera un week-end sur deux questions
de matthieu alterman genre à penser que
c'est dommage que l'émission n'est pas
retransmise en 3d parce que c'est
vraiment pas c'est impressionnant quand
même ah bah oui ah bah oui c'est loin
m'intéresse vous avez fait l'aube story
vous ai fait la ferme des célébrités
non non pas par des mois la branche de
l'arbre les anges de la mésange
l'étonnant de l'aisance cad sortez-moi
l'ag vérité il s'appelle le la villa des
coeurs brisés je ne connaissais pas j'ai
appris cette existence il n'y a pas une
fois vous vous êtes dit là je fais une
émission je la sens pas je suis pas bien
dans le cas lors de l'émission d'entre
elles parce que l'appareil de
tomographie d'émission sur 17 ans donc
en fait j'en fais pas toutes les années
donc je fais le loft j'ai fait les anges
chebaa cinq six ans plus tard et cette
haine on m'a proposé la ville a donc
voix se soient pas que 3 4 pénalités qui
ont fait les moyens peut-être vous dites
et n'a pas vu que tu regardes aucune
aucune le loft m'a fait connaître sans
témoin de là c'était incroyable avec le
ficfa le loir-et-cher pour longer la
question oui aujourd'hui entre en un mot
si tu devais là aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que tu aimerais faire
qu'est ce que tu as moins que
chroniqueuse émission de télé du cinéma
encore une télé réalité qu'est ce que tu
aimerais faire
ah non là je ne sais pas j'aimerais
découvrir le métier de l'actrice ça
c'est sûr d'actrice alors est-ce que
vous et pardon oui est ce que ça vous
plairait par exemple d'être autour de la
table ou deux dans tpm pipolo chronicle
chez moi comme dans le monde comme abb
et oui on a très bons chronos que dans
dix mille d'entre eux étaient avérés ou
ici tu aimerais de chroniqueuse oui ça
me plairait beaucoup bien sûr
au gabon on se connaît tous connaître
série le tout est question nice était
gratuite va falloir environ suis pas
grave
[Applaudissements]
effectivement il faudra enlever
quelqu'un comme maxi riches étaient
gratuites ou même voir tu payes tu peux
avoir ta place
question aux téléspectateurs pourquoi
est-ce que tu as refusé de faire d'al sa
danse avec les stars c'est un énorme
regret d'ailleurs puisque en fait quand
on me l'a proposé c'est quand j'étais
encore ronde me voyez pas m'afficher en
petite tenue à blanc par respect enfin
pour moi donc c'est eux leur impose
maintenant il ya bien de savoir ben
wallace était enfin nous regarde je me
dis est-ce que qu'est ce que tu voudrais
faire ça je dois le faire dans sa saison
comme saison prochaine c'est pour moi
j'appelle ara aprikian response
l'instructeur avons compensé un sujet
prochain c'était luana peut-elle revenir
sur le devant de la scène
oui non est-ce qu'on a la réponse
téléspectateurs l'a jamais quitté c'est
notre question fait ce qu'on veut elle a
toujours tout le monde sait qui est là
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on n'a pas
la réponse